welcome to the David Pakman show one of
the large
you
you
you
all right welcome everybody we are wow
how far are we 17 minutes from the start
of today's chess tournament looks like
I'm coming in a little bit hot let's see
if I can turn my gain down a bit there
we go I'm in my other setup right now
I'm in my office rather than my studio
we are on the precipice of the third
ever David Pakman show chess tournament
these are just fun it's something to do
tacos were great some of you may have
been with me for my earth this is
actually the second live stream of the
day or life stream as some of my viewers
call them over 40,000 40,000 people were
on my live stream earlier today with
this bizarre urgent press conference
that Donald Trump abruptly called
and then just attacked Joe Biden for an
hour so I'll play a couple of clips from
that but this is not going to be a super
political stream if you want to play in
this tournament where we have 369
players currently registered go to david
pakman.com slash chess or use the link
that is in the description either on
twitch or on youtube we had 500 people
play in my first chess tournament we had
732 in my second chess tournament I
would love to get to 732 were only at
369 so I'm suggesting that you jump into
the tournament it's completely free to
play we've got eight players rated over
8,000 2,000 not 8,000 I am really
towards the bottom actually quite
frankly and we have people of all
different ratings even as low as 600 so
I think it's going to be a really really
great event and we have 15 minutes or so
to register and I invite you to do so
it's free we're not I'm not you don't
have to be good this is you're gonna be
matched up against people with rough
roughly your same rating if you have a
provisional rating you'll be you know up
against people oh and you'll very
quickly end up playing people roughly of
your skill level these will be three
plus two games
three minutes plus two seconds per move
and we unfortunately can't control
cheating and in the first two
tournaments one of the three top three
people got caught cheating and
retroactive Lee I had to remove their
trophy unfortunately it's really really
sad but it's like come on guys this is
for a community so don't do any of that
[ __ ] david pakman.com slash chess is
the place to register we are at three
hundred and seventy nine three eighty so
let's let's keep that going just a
couple things if you did miss earlier
here is donald trump claiming that joe
biden is against windows this is from my
stream earlier that this was one of the
most arranged things trump has ever done
take a look at this mandate net zero
carbon emission it's coming out of only
one year but we're just gonna deal with
this for homes offices and all new
buildings by 2030 that basically means
no windows no nothing windows are done
no more windows if Biden's president
it's very hard to do I tell people when
they want to go into some of these
buildings how are your eyes because they
won't be good in five years and I hope
you don't mind
cold office space no heat either so very
very strange really really strange stuff
and then here's Brett Beier on Fox News
admitting that if Barack Obama called an
urgent press conference at the Oval
Office and then did a campaign speech
Republicans would have been going crazy
here's Brett Bay or himself admitting it
spoke for fifty two minutes before
taking a question presidents in the past
by tradition have stayed away from overt
campaign rhetoric from the Rose Garden
or the White House but it is the
president's discretion it is worth
noting however to be fair that had
President Obama made this kind of speech
from the Rose Garden Republicans on
Capitol Hill would likely have been up
in arms but thumbs 112 days sixteen
weeks to the day before Election Day
yeah and so if we take a look at some of
the
that have been coming out lately
obviously it's not looking great Florida
gravis poll has Biden plus 10 which is
just brutal
you know Missouri we would expect Trump
to win same with Montana nothing super
notable there another Florida Paul has
Biden plus six how is he doing here in
Massachusetts just out of curiosity
Biden plus 31 Wow and then of course in
Texas there's a poll recently that as
Biden plus five on average it is a tie
right now in Texas I mean it's crazy
what's going on it was one of the most
ridiculous events I've seen the numbers
are really bad here in the United States
sixty-four thousand new cases again
death spiking to 908 Florida with 132
that's a single-day record Texas with
129 that's a single-day record and as
you can see so today is not yet here the
previous high for Texas was 121 and
today Texas had 129 death tragic Florida
had 132 today and as you can see here in
Florida the previous high there was 119
so just absolutely terrible there's
there's no way around it and it's listen
the cases were way worse in early July
than they were in late June June these
death numbers are related to the cases
in late June so the numbers are likely
going to go up up up if you're just
joining us we have 11 minutes to go
until the third ever David Pakman show
chess tournament starts please join guys
this is free the target is 733 players
we are at 397 okay the first tournament
I did 500 people played it was fantastic
in June we did the second tournament 732
people played I just want to beat that
by one okay so we are 333 away 400
people currently registered we have nine
players rated 2,000 or above we have one
player rated 601 at 799 I am towards the
bottom of the pack but who cares who
cares and
yeah we're good I see people like see
service saying let's not make this too
much of a political stream I think that
that's that's fair that's very we want
to be here for this is a sort of
different different sort of thing oh and
my phone is going off my friends are
starting to I should silence that that's
rude
I apologize for that this is going I
think this is going to be a great
tournament and you can find the
tournament by going to david pakman.com
slash chess okay david pakman.com slash
chess you know something just as a
really weird thing today may be the best
day potentially in years on the David
Pakman show YouTube channel we had
through clearly some error I think
YouTube made an error
we had 40,000 people almost 36 something
watching my earlier livestream we gained
I think it was more than 2,000 well that
was weird
something just blacked did everything go
black for you guys for a second that was
strange maybe that was just my monitor
that was weird
we had like 2000 new YouTube subscribers
today it was insane and it may end up
being our best literally our best day
ever on YouTube which is crazy and what
better way to cap it then with a
beautiful chess tournament which you can
find at david pakman.com slash chess 419
421 people registered thanks to ASAP
miles and spaceman spiff for subscribing
over on Twitch yet which has been going
ok I mean right now the goal is to get
to 40,000 followers people are asking
about pogchamp what i'm authorized to
say right now and i want to be very very
careful because there's very powerful
forces that you know i don't want to
anger i have been invited to play in
pogchamp stew and i have been in direct
contact with Hikaru Nakamura
okay that's all I can say for now and
there will be forthcoming announcements
and a lot of really really crazy things
so that's uh that's at some point in the
future
Sam Dean is checking in with a YouTube
super chat and says good luck mate yeah
I mean listen there's some very very
good players here we have nine players
rated over 2,000 we have I guess a total
of 12 players at 1,900 or above 20 play
18 17 players at 1,800 I'm just in it
for the fun and for the lulz as I say
432 people registered I'm worried we're
not going to best the last tournament
and I've been promoting this thing for a
couple weeks maybe well I don't know I'm
worried but we want to try to get to 733
players we have 8 minutes to go until
this starts we are at 434 please
register this is my please clap moment
please register we need to 99 to 99
again people wondering how to find the
link david pakman.com slash chess or you
can look in the description on the
stream on YouTube or twitch but if
you're watching anywhere else like
Facebook or Twitter just go to david
pakman.com slash chess that would be the
place to do it and it's in the title I
mean listen guys it's everywhere can I
put the link in the chat wow people it's
like there's half a lot of high
maintenance stuff going on isn't there
I'm gonna paste the link a few times in
twitch and also over on YouTube if
destiny is streaming right now with the
boat s's yep so can people people go
over there and tell them to join my join
my stream there's people ready got a
band people this is so annoying
yeah alright people are already getting
banned it's unbelievable unbelievabl
already david pakman.com slash chess yes
that's that's the way to spell
PA que ma n and we have six and a half
minutes until the start of this
tournament we are up to four hundred and
forty players anxiously waiting I am one
of those four hundred and forty producer
Pat Forde notified me that he is going
to be playing let's see where he is all
right
producer Pat Forde he is there he is Oh
provisionally rated at 1500
okay so Pat is going to have a real
situation on his hands that's going to
be interesting Tyler and the residents
said I showed my doctor your stream
today and he said he's never seen
numbers that high before I see what you
did there now that's what I call alpha
good luck and get checkmates yes indeed
we're going to do it yeah I was able to
go like 10 minutes without banning
anybody you know if I was able to open
up discord I would let Steven Kenneth
destiny bonel ii know about this
tournament but it might cause a problem
let me see here hold on let me see if I
can do that
discord let's see here something very
weird is going on with my hair
Oh God discord is updating this could
shut down my entire computer let's see
here here it is okay destiny hey FYI
chess tournament starting in five
minutes
come join with the Bo Tessa's david
pakman.com slash chess alright maybe
we'll see what happens with destiny it's
just like a last ditch effort we have
463 players registered we have five
minutes oh wait hold on there we go we
have five minutes to go and I invite you
to come on in david pakman.com slash
chess this is free I'm not selling you
anything this is just participate
because it's fun that's all it is and no
titled players yet we did have two
titled players last time and
international master Eric Rosen who I
will be doing a stream with soon a
crossover event
it's going to be a very special episode
of the David Pakman show
Eric one actually both of my last
tournaments and he was one of two
international masters let's see what's
up with destiny
yeah destiny seems very tied up he seems
to have a lot he seems to be juggling a
lot over there oh and I should have
invited hutch as well I just didn't
think about it I just didn't think about
it but we're gonna get it we're gonna
get it done very very powerfully we're
down to the last four minutes for for
four minutes I do have some new members
I want to thank Laurie Harding is new
member number one today
Eric McDonald just signed up on my
website and his new member number two
Lucas Starbuck his new member number
three reminds me of the Battlestar
Galactica days Ryan Hodge is new member
number four Nicole Heller is new member
number five and Tom Mae is new member
number six appreciate that guys yeah
feel free I will try to keep up with new
member thank-yous and as you can see
we've reset our goal to 25 hutch is
playing poker right now okay got it got
it got it got it
all right well listen we're gonna just
do what we can you know I can't I can't
control all factors we are just 25
players from 500 I think it would be
great to at least be at 500 before we
start a lot of people have been banned I
see the discussion happening on Lee
chess a lot of people during these
during my tournaments have been banned
for cheating it's just lame guys it's
super super lame don't do it and I mean
just just don't do it it's you know
cheating in a non you know in a
tournament come on come on guys it's
horrible we are at 480 players at david
pakman.com slash chess and we have
players ranging from 600 all the way up
to 23 19 Kasparov wannabe we do have a
hype train starting over on Twitch we
actually succeeded at a level 5
hypetrain earlier during my stream it
was an explosive stream and I love
people saying how would you even cheat
that's a beautiful question I'm not
gonna say that's great it's fantastic
that's exactly the attitude I wanted how
would you even cheat you would you
wouldn't it doesn't make any sense to do
it okay
destiny is playing poker oh my god
that's horrifying
can you imagine imagine playing poker
right now we are just sixteen players
from 500 with 90 seconds left until the
start of the tournament david pakman.com
slash chess were also simultaneously in
a level 1 hype train on Twitch we are
also taking Super chats on YouTube we
are down to 12 players to go to get to
512 players to go 11 players to go
beautiful oh Kasparov wannabe is also
over in the twitch chat that's
interesting how does someone even get to
be rated 2319 like I'm gonna be taking
some online lessons soon that you guys
are gonna be streaming them and I have
more information about that upcoming but
like I just don't even know how you get
220 like you have to have a natural
talent right to get to 2300 I can't
think of any other way to do it we are
five players away from 505 players away
from 500 two players one player and we
are now over 500 remember the target is
733 we have 30 seconds to go people can
keep jumping in
during the tournament remember that you
can you can join the tournament at any
time we are at 517 seconds to go I
expect to hear the countdown countdown
very soon here we go
9 8 beautiful 7 6 5 4 3 keep joining
guys you can keep joining here we go
players are being paired and we are off
alright
I'm actually going to start today with
I'm gonna play a Kings Indian right now
and we'll see how I do with it off we go
hypetrain continues two and a half
minutes to go I'm gonna try the Kings
Indian I did not play this at all
I've been messing around with it since
the last tournament so we're going to
see I believe the move is I think it's
this and then maybe here here I think is
the way typically to develop on the
King's Indian and we are very very
powerfully in the middle of this
tournament yeah I think actually here
then usually I played this or don't
totally remember it actually but it's a
pseudo King's Indian to the extent that
I remember it I guess is as far as I'm
going with it
it's not racist it's just the name yeah
it's not no no it'sit's fine alright I
think here and then now is where I don't
remember I thought it was maybe this
we'll see
I think it's literally Indian like from
India um yeah I think here so far my
development has been unobstructed
although I don't remember if I'm
actually playing this opening correctly
Kingfisher 28 my first opponent you can
join it david pakman.com slash chess now
do I want to do I think I'm gonna try
this and see where we get with that um
now what though now what let me think
here here I don't know that that really
works
about a minute time advantage but that
is accelerating okay I mean I don't feel
inclined you're here I'm not really
inclined to get this Bishop out of the
way I think I'd rather play my own
developing move now I wonder if here I'm
just gonna go here I know that there's
the option of the fianchetto on the
opposite side with this bishop but my
understanding was that if you have these
squares available that in the King's
Indian with white that's typically where
you want to start what is a weak point
here so here that could actually be a
problem for me because I think if
there's a big trade yeah that's not so
good hmm I think I do
think I almost have to take as otherwise
the bishop is in a problematic position
I think I need to try to unleash this
bishop soon
so if here here actually I think I'm
okay there I might try to clear this oh
[ __ ] no that wasn't a good idea that may
have been a big mistake that may have
been a big mistake I think he might have
missed it I think that might have been a
mistake I think I just could have
potentially given something away in my
opponent missed it
where do we want to go next here hmm
I'm actually unclear in this position
there's probably some obviously best
move don't think I want to double up I
might try this oh no I mean I would that
would be an illegal move let's get the
King out of the way now it's not looking
so good now it's not looking so good I
think there's actually a I think I have
a problem on this square actually yeah
right
good thing I did that wonder if could
try it think now I think if here I take
this way
now do I push now I don't think that
makes sense think I'm gonna bring this
in have to be careful here certainly got
out of the way of that
[Music]
no might go here and try to get this out
of the way see that's not such a good
idea let's try this I think this is okay
now it's a time scramble let's try note
than I've got here we go
schemes taking quite some time
here we go don't know if this really
helps me that much I think I just take
here again here this would be beautiful
didn't happen so let's see if I take
then takes here oh here we go wow wow
wow wow wow wow okay that was it that
was that was huge that was huge
okay who do we have playing we have Wow
some people already won two games we
have 550 people playing remember you can
still join in david pakman.com slash
chess yeah I'm gonna be churning some
chess ideas throughout this just going
to be churning churning churning chess
ideas david pakman.com slash chests 550
to players right now and i would love it
if we got 732 is our record and i would
love to get to that get to 7 7 33 all
right let's go Kings Indian again
going at it again castling
maybe I'll go for the fianchetto this
time just just for old times sake think
I'm still okay to keep my procedure
going I think here here here right is
this that what I'm looking to do and
we've got see does that work because
here here here yeah I think that's okay
oh I think oh no that doesn't work
actually that doesn't work buh-buh-buh
so need to figure out what to do here
maybe just out of the way looking here
so if here then probably backs up yeah
now this is blocked but let's get the
night into the action yeah you can still
join it david pakman.com slash chess
that's still very much available to you
I would like to be able to do something
here but I think this night is what
would prevent me right because then it's
not I'm not really forking in an
effective way that way so if I take and
today I don't think there's any reason
to do that I think maybe here yeah I
think I don't know that I have that many
other great options this were to move
you know you've got a mate in one threat
there it is that's not going to work
um I guess here kind of getting pushed
around thinking
it's open to all for people asking david
pakman.com slash chess / chess that's
the place to go alright I don't know
that I feel immediately drawn to defend
here I think this is the direction I
want to go hmm where's my blunder going
to come from I wonder I know that
there's some players who sometimes
gambit the Queen and so if there's a
point at which it makes sense for me to
give the Queen away you know let me know
about that all right so I'm sort of sort
of pinned here I think I might just put
pressure this way and if necessary just
take right there yep okay I mean I guess
that's not altogether bad I do advance
the pawn so obviously I wonder so if I
kick the night away then can just take
here and then I'm forked so I don't want
to do that maybe I try this it's feeling
a little risky but let's see see where
we are
about a 40 second time advantage last
game did not come down to time
ultimately okay so if here then here and
I'm gonna get knocked around if I take
here then here and then that that
actually might work unless I'm missing
something let's see the URL is david
pakman.com slash chess okay so it could
go here or here or just retreat i'm my
instinct is just to retreat right now i
don't know that i want to be lined up
with the queen necessarily but i am
thinking yeah that's not a problem i
think i kind of like the idea of pinning
this pawn am I missing anything here
let's try it
oh Jesus did I just miss Mayton one was
this Mayton one oh my god you got to be
kidding me you got to be kidding me
alright let's go after the Queen I just
miss Mayton one Jesus Christ oh my god
oh my god that was insane
let's see I think this this work no that
doesn't really work actually I think it
might because of this right I think that
works potentially my god matin one I
missed
unbelievable unbelievable
ah there it is um okay I think I've got
to start making some kind of move here I
think we're gonna back off here
momentarily yeah I needed some better
ideas there I'm going here this would be
a beauty maybe not working so well okay
wait
takes oh no that's not that's not a fork
that's not exactly what I'm looking for
let's take here this point I'm sort of
grasping at straws not really sure let's
take here just trying to open some space
really I think we've got a fork here yep
so now it's just a scramble I think I
take and here we go
um not really sure now oh boy
and I think can't move right because of
the pin and here and now I'm not sure
need to start pushing pawn maybe now
it's gonna be a scramble let me think
here
this is getting complicated I'm gonna
take here I think I'm gonna go I think I
think this is the pawn here right
and here keep going over some point I'm
gonna have to defend that and I think
now it's a scramble oh boy that may have
been a mistake I think I almost did have
them there now I've got to think about
this I think it's oh god no god I'm
screwed I made a mistake there there's a
very specific way to play this which is
checkmate all the time but maybe I can
force a stalemate
Wow I'm gonna have to really review that
one all right let's just move on
resign yep I want to analyze that I mean
it's like I could have pushed that for a
stalemate potentially where was that I
had this is where okay so what did I do
oh my god right so I should have gone
here and that was checkmate oh my god so
I miss checker at checkmate twice
unbelievable all right let's go back to
the tournament Jesus that was
embarrassing
that was really bad let's stick with
Kings Indian horrible absolutely
horrible
by the way you can join it david
pakman.com slash chess yeah some people
wanted me to go for the stalemate but it
seemed reasonable to just move on I
don't remember what the right play is
here is it there because we're not
finding out in the immediate the
fianchetto did not really work that
great for me so i think i'm not gonna go
with it this game yeah play it a little
differently actually let's see I'm
liking the idea of right now from the
standpoint of medical now let me think
about this
thanks Jeremy for upgrading your
membership I think I like the idea of
the night there
I do think I've miss played this already
to some degree but I'm trying to get my
queen out for whatever reason it's
appealing to me
let's go here first could get the Queen
trapped but I'm feeling like playing it
a little riskier right now so there's a
nice fork right does this fork work I
think it does
so who's winning right now anybody know
who's leading the tournament right now
so let me think Queen will probably move
yep so we'll go here and then now what
would be interesting would be if I can
go to him into it then I've got a
beautiful move could he possibly fall
for this let's see did I calculate that
correctly ah did not okay
well it's still a piece right imagine if
here oh wait no because of this I can't
fork there interesting though
thought I had an idea there thought I
had an idea
so do I take the free pond for now I
guess I take the pawn oh my god what am
i doing I almost just gave away my Queen
Jesus that would have been a bad idea
that would have been a really bad idea
[Music]
here here then I gotta get out of the
way I think I take it here at what point
should I give my Queen away is that a
question so this is undefended right now
I'll go here because I think that I'm
still defending
you guys almost saw my first queen gift
[Laughter]
I'm gonna try to avoid giving away my
queen
guys if you're looking to join the
tournament just type in david pakman.com
slash chess it's really simple david
pakman.com slash chess thanks donkey
show and willis 87 for subscribing
thanks to Jeremy Hughes and psycho jet
black Avant Tom oh I think I just missed
the move ok there it is
um free Queen ok that wasn't a good move
and then a free rook where is checkmate
though checkmate could be elusive here
got to be able to finish it off and it's
not exactly clear to me I could have a
fork here if I could get over but I
don't even know if I need to get
involved in that maybe you know let me
think I think I'm gonna play here so
we've got a potential discovered check
and then attack here and I guess I take
this
where is the checkmate I actually don't
know let's see and then here hmm it's
actually I mean I guess I'll just keep
taking stuff it's here right this has
got to be it and then here there it is
all right let's go back to the
tournament who's winning right now we
have a feed a master playing all right
here's my first game as black and I'm
again going to go this time with the
Kings Indian as black I've not played
this yet this tournament I think this is
a special case for this scenario and I
don't remember how I'm supposed to play
it but it didn't come up Castle I think
I will go with the fee on keto if
allowed
then here here and here maybe do I need
to worry about that I don't know that I
need to worry about it in the immediate
I think still 55 minutes left in the
tournament plenty of time for anybody to
join it david pakman.com slash chess
free it's just a good time that's all it
is let's get the night out thinking here
also I wonder if there's any opportunity
for a check from either of these squares
which are undefended right now
now wait a second I do need to be
careful here uh yeah I think I need to
be careful there so do I just take
because my Queens under attack actually
let me think about this here and then
this is actually I think this is okay oh
no but then nope it actually won't work
although then I could take I think this
might end up with me winning a piece
yeah here here and then here yeah okay
that'll that works so now where do I
build the attack is the question let's
see I mean it's at least put it on now
that doesn't work the knight doesn't
move that way could try it let's just
try it I'm gonna try to bait with this
pawn and see if I can get that going
let's just see let's just see what
happens and obviously if takes then here
or maybe not maybe I just go for the
threat of yeah uh right so maybe here I
guess I can just trade there if
necessary but it would save checkmate
obviously
still have some possibilities here okay
that's pin so that's actually not a
threat right because they can't that
would not work here here I have to be
careful though because as soon as this
moves then the Queen is under attack to
think about that okay so wait probably
here right this is the most likely move
or actually no well it could be here oh
okay that's interesting no longer pinned
so I've got to remember if this isn't
pinned could lose it at any time I mean
I think I still take the rook
now what now what is the question I
think maybe here to defend this piece
maybe does that work so now we're just
trading and I just stay up a little bit
okay so let's say here and then here
here I mean it's I'm losing a lot of
time I think I have to take though let's
start putting pawns on white squares
right since this is a dark squared
bishop and let's start getting out of
the way maybe do I just double up I mean
I'm not exactly sure what other kind of
attack I can mount now I'll trade
they're still up the exchange that be a
reasonable trade then what though
then I've got to this square is defended
okay so oh that was a mistake yeah there
we go all right back to tournament who's
winning now I'm gonna just briefly pause
where can it pause okay I just want to
see what's going on fm2 2808 join oh my
god wait did I just lose my points by
pausing oh no oh my god so we got a lot
of player I didn't even get a chance to
see that Indian dude says shout out to
my sri lankan and ruined and brothers
handling covered like a boss let's keep
going with Kings Indian I mean it's it's
going okay so far provisional rating
here if you're just joining us you can
join yourself at david pakman.com slash
chess link is also in the description on
youtube and twitch
let's let's keep going with the fee on
keto that worked last time
think creating space also I think in
this position it's actually okay to
undeveloped if this comes forward yeah
and if I take take then I'm undeveloped
again II way I think then of course I've
got the Queen but then it's just you
know we trade Queens which I don't
really want to do so I think I'm going
back here maybe with that pawn it's kind
of never really clear to me
okay I'm not super worried about that
anything to this attack not really would
be interesting to look at this oh wait a
second actually now that doesn't work
let's go here not worried about this
we'll just take